In the Netherlands, the International Criminal Court...
...sentenced a warlord from the Democratic Republic of Congo, Bosco Ntaganda,...
...to 30 years' imprisonment after he was convicted of crimes including murder, rape and sexual slavery.
In Austria, Iran alleged that the UN IAEA inspector it blocked from a nuclear site last week...
...tested positive for suspected traces of explosive nitrates.
The inspector later left Iran without completing her visit.
In Senegal, residents in a Dakar suburb said they would rather stay in the country...
...than face the dangers of traveling to Europe without the necessary legal documents,...
...a day after France announced tighter immigration policies.
In Mexico, the city of La Mora prepares to receive at least 1,000 visitors...
...preceding the first funerals of some of the nine victims slain by drug cartel gunmen.
Finally from China, of the nine people convicted...
...of producing and trafficking fentanyl and other forbidden drugs,...
...the two principal culprits Liu Yong and Jiang Juhua, were sentenced to death.